vocês sabiam que a partir de resíduos
sólidos gerados nas indústrias coureiro
e pesqueira
podemos obter biomateriais pra
desenvolver produtos biocompatíveis com
os organismo com o organismo humano e
mais uma pessoal e que esses projetos
esses produtos são desenvolvidos com
alunos do ensino médio e técnico de uma
escola técnica na cidade de franca com
idade entre 14 e 18 anos
eu chamo joana d'arc perto de souza
minha formação é toda na área de química
eu tenho graduação mestrado e doutorado
pela universidade estadual de campinas
unicamp e pós doutorado pela
universidade de harvard
com 25 anos de idade
como se deu esse pessoal é eu venho de
uma família super pobre super humilde eu
me interessei pela química ainda bem
criança porque devido à dificuldade
econômica
meu pai ele ganhou uma casa para morar
na área do conjunto onde ele trabalhava
ou seja nasce dentro da área de um
curtume fortune é uma indústria que
produz couros tá pra vários setores
indústria de calçados bolsas e vestuário
assim por diante
e eu comecei a ler aprendi a ler não é
comecei a ler com três anos e meio de
idade com quatro anos a última
oportunidade de ingressar no 1º ano do
ensino fundamental com 14 anos eu
consegui entrar na usp e na unicamp e da
unesp e escolheu unicamp para estudando
com 17 anos era formado em química fiz
mestrado doutorado e durante o doutorado
devidas às boas publicações eu tive o
convite para fazer
pós doc na universidade de harvard e
tudo estava caminhando muito bem
tinha proposta a mas infelizmente
pessoal quando eu estava mais ou menos
um ano e meio de pós doutorado é meu pai
meu irmão meu pai falecer um prazo de um
mês e três dias
vim para fran fui para franca voltei dos
estados unidos determinou é o pós
doutorado
nesse meio tempo minha mãe ficou muito
doente ou seja tomar a opção de voltar
pra frente pra cuidar da minha mãe
voltei muito desanimado ou seja o que
vou fazer no brasil que vou fazer em
franca
e hoje eu sei que foi a melhor decisão
que eu tomei na minha vida mas na
naquele naquele momento estava muito
desanimada mas aí pessoal troxas de um
concurso na escola técnica etec
professor carmelino corrêa júnior quer
do centro paula souza conhecido como a
escola agrícola de franca
fiz concurso comecei assim meio
desanimada e mas aí eu resolvi fazer a
diferença mudar toda aquela realidade cá
e como foi mudar de fazer a diferença
foi trazer pra para ensino médio e
técnico tanto a iniciação científica que
é tradicional na na graduação então eu
trouxe isso pra se desenvolvido na
educação básica ou seja no ensino médio
e técnico
porque eu tomei essa decisão logo que
comecei a trabalhar nessa escola eu
percebi que a evasão escolar é muito
grande
a maioria dos alunos da escola possui um
nível social muito baixo uma escola onde
é que fica na fazenda por ser uma escola
agrícola uma escola de periferia e ea à
falta de motivação a falta de interesse
dos alunos muito grande uma baixa
autoestima então assim a evasão escolar
entre 1º e 2º ano tanto do ensino médio
como cinto médio como técnico é muito
grande então como ajudar contribuir para
mudar essa situação lá dentro da escola
tá aí já admite projeto a fapesp
consegui a bolsa de iniciação científica
e comecei a
os alunos pra iniciação científica e foi
assim que é isso você funcionário da
escola ou empregado da escola então se
eles explicarem na escola o que é isso
mas aí eu comecei lá pessoal a trabalhar
e ouvir comecei a perceber o seguinte à
educação e ciência tem o poder de
transformar vidas táxis vão ver isso
mais para frente o quão isso é
verdadeiro produzem cérebro está que
serão as cabeças pensantes para o nosso
futuro
eu me interessei pessoal pela orientação
de alunos da educação básica porque eu
acho que o ensino está a a ciência está
a pesquisa tem que começar cedo porque
aí começa a gerar frutos por muitos e
muitos anos porque no ensino básico que
a maioria dos alunos se perdem a eles
nem chega numa universidade em a
inclusão desses alunos cá o ensino médio
ensino técnico em um projeto de pesquisa
de iniciação científica desenvolve tal
pensamento lógico nesses alunos
desenvolvem características fundamentais
tá nesses alunos que ele vai escolher
como né uma das características as
competências técnicas que vai ser muito
importante para esse aluno ele tanto
dentro do rio do sul como ele se ele
seguir uma vida acadêmica
então com isso começando a desenvolver
projetos de pesquisa
nós o que começamos a mudar a cara da
escola mas no momento de no início ele
quando pensei quais projetos de pesquisa
e iremos desenvolver
aí eu pensei num fator muito importante
fomos olhar os problemas ambientais da
nossa cidade da cidade de franca que ela
é conhecida como a capital do calçado e
à geração de resíduos ali no setor
coureiro calçadista é muito grande então
comecei a ler o seguinte desenvolvimento
dos dias de ensino porque o seguinte
tinha pessoal que sair daquela
metodologia tradicional ele da sala de
aula o aluno não suporta mais o
professor estava escrevendo na lousa o
aluno estava mexendo no celular
ou seja não temos mais interesse por
aquelas metodologias tradicionais de
ensino tinha que mudar isso tá novas
metodologias de ensino pra
motivar para tornar o ensino e prazeroso
o aluno ele tem vontade na sala de aula
vontade de colaborar tório vontade de
aprender está à vontade de querer ser
alguém na vida tem ambição na vida e
tinha que mudar isso outro problema
desconstruiu o conceito de química é uma
disciplina chata isso foi complicado
escola
então pessoal ou seja a educação é a
arma mais poderosa para vencermos os
obstáculos da vida então comecei a
desenvolver pesquisa baseado nos
problemas ambientais da cidade que são o
que os resíduos sólidos gerados no setor
coureiro calçadista da cidade de franca
eles são o que o depositário de formas
de forma inadequada no aterro ali não é
um aterro sanitário da cidade
aqueles três êxitos na parte de cima dos
lucros eles têm que ser no estado aqui
de são paulo eles têm que ser enviado
pra esse sim dois aterros especializados
que são muito é um paulino tremembé para
receber seis idosos só que por causa do
valor do custo que os empresários fazem
estoque com esses lucros em tambores e
guardo a icw elenco é construir
barracões para estocar esses resíduos
vocês têm idéia do ano passado o
empresário me procurou a empresa fechar
ele tinha um milhão de toneladas de lodo
estocado em e mais além
pessoal e durante está o processo de
transformação da pele chegar ea pele do
frigorífico com pelo até essa pele se
transformado em couro preto uma
indústria de calçado bolsa vestuários do
flamengo um tom sem sabia que franca
gera podia 218 toneladas de resíduos ea
quantidade de água é o seguinte o frete
em torno de 10 curtumes e tem 350 mil
habitantes pois bem esses 10 curtos eles
consumir uma quantidade de água
equivalente à população do dobro da
cidade
por dia eles consomem uma quantidade de
água equivalente à população de 700 mil
habitantes está e é uma água que eu seja
perdida e nós já tão no brasil já está
sofrendo com a escassez hídrica
ou seja a gente tem que fazer alguma
coisa pra lá está contornando esses
problemas vão mudar
é como começar a dar nossa contribuição
então todos os projetos de pesquisas que
nós desenvolvemos foi baseado nos
problemas dos resíduos e efluentes
gerados no setor coureiro calçadista e
desenvolvemos ou seja vários vários
produtos
outro produto na região de franca é a
questão dos resíduos de peixe tem essa
cidade que é fã e ficar próximo a 50
quilômetros de franco tem também na
região de franca
muitos criadores de peixe e as escamas
de peixe geradas ali na indústria
pesqueira é um problema muito grande
tá o empresário que ele também tem que
depositar no ateu então o outro resíduo
que nós incluímos no meu pai ali na como
matéria-prima passar trabalho é então o
pessoal aí começamos a trabalhar o
reaproveitamento de resíduos em abril em
engenharia de tecidos foi capaz de
transformar esses resíduos sólidos no
caso do resíduo cor da dengue e coureiro
exibidos classe 1 em dois produtos
importantes para a saúde humana que é o
cimento ósseo a pele humana artificial
são dois dos projetos como o tambor
dentre os vários projetos que nós
desenvolvemos votar apresentando esses
dois aqui pra vocês tá e com a
participação a inclusão além dos alunos
na iniciação científica então o cimento
ósseo ele foi obtido a partir da
reciclagem de resíduos desse das
indústrias coleira e pesqueira
tá vocês sabiam que segundo a associação
nacional de transporte público o brasil
ele gasta anualmente cerca de 28 bilhões
tá com as vítimas de trânsito são
anualmente em média 37 mil né vítimas
por ano e sendo que 10 desse valor 6%
são fatais
nos estados unidos a organização a
organização mundial de saúde
ela diz que os estados unidos já gasta
30 bilhões com as vítimas de trânsito
são em torno de 600 seiscentas mil
vítimas por ano
e na idade e até coloca uma idade de 5
há 44 anos e desde totais montante 10%
são fatais e um dado interessante que
até os médicos reclamam que é muito
desconhecido da população brasileira é
que dentre a doação de órgãos pode se
doar os ossos só que na maioria das
vezes as famílias não aceitam isso como
doação de ossos como doação de pele de
bella que eu vou falar mais na frente
então assim é um dado bem desconhecido
pela da da população brasileira e na
hora de doação muitas famílias não
aceitando mais ossos são no máximo
pessoal brasil todo doação de ossos não
passa de 30 doações anuais
tá olha a metodologia então com o como
tabu está dando a nossa contribuição
então nós estudamos ali junto com os
alunos
a constituição dos ossos humanos possuem
vários constituintes pessoal
os principais são colágeno na fase
orgânica em torno de 25% e
hidroxiapatita na fase no orgânica dos
ossos em torno de 75% é e como baratear
e isso cimento ósseo que só existe no
mercado que fica em torno de mil dólares
o quilo isso tudo dados fornecidos pelos
médicos está em outro dado interessante
é o seguinte o colágeno no mercado
pessoal no brasil índice em torno de 5
em búzios de colágeno onde elas vendem o
colágeno para as várias indústrias
alimentícia cosmética farmacêutica é um
valor em torno de 130 reais o quilo
nós conseguimos extrair o colágeno com a
mesma característica de resíduo classe 1
decod de curtume está ele o cromo nós
conseguimos separar o cromo a um valor
de 80 centavos o quilo pessoal
hidroxiapatita vamos conversar com os
médicos a hidroxiapatita que existe no
mercado ela é sintética aí os médicos
até reclamar um kim tenha elas por elas
carregam tem ali com elas por impurezas
reações químicas é onde determinadas
pessoas por pé
apresentou rejeição às vezes em prol de
alguma coisa eu sei depende do organismo
da pessoa apresentar rejeição estudando
nós começamos a estudar vários resíduos
saber de onde poderia estar ainda
hidroxiapatita ela está presente em
alguns tipos de escama de peixe
aí nós conseguimos extrair a
hidroxiapatita natural da escama de
peixe a 1 do valor de 50 centavos o
quilo no mercado 3 mil reais o quilo
pessoal
preparamos então o cimento ósseo
já a partir desse constituintes e onde
ele está sendo testado agora está sendo
toda a fase de análises químicas por um
professor da da faculdade de medicina da
usp de ribeirão preto onde ele diz o
seguinte e cimento ósseo ele pode fazer
a reconstituição remodelação tá
tratamento de tumores ósseos por exemplo
a pessoa tem um acidente de moto perdeu
parte do osso a tendência é ficar com
uma perna menor que a outra
nesse caso aqui o cimento ósseo o médico
ele remou dela aquela pai reconstitui
aquela parte óssea aquela massa óssea
perdida e aí fecha a cirurgia e cimento
ósseo ele favorece o crescimento de um
osso novo e conforme esse osso novo vai
crescendo vai absorvendo e cimento ósseo
tá então seja não precisa depois se
retirar e a um valor de cimento ósseo 29
centavos o quilo
tá então pessoal ou seja que têm várias
aplicações no caso também de tumores
ósseos e e aqui vou mostrar pra vocês a
os alunos da que participaram deste
projeto
nós ganhamos o prêmio do conselho
regional de química de 2017 nós somos a
única instituição que ganhamos por três
vezes o prêmio do conselho regional de
química
esse trabalho nós apresentamos na
olimpíada de gênios o ano passado nos
estados unidos foi muito interessante
porque a participaram 75 países e 39
estados americanos nós ficamos em quarto
lugar
aqui bank marketing e outros prêmios e
um interessante pessoal pra vocês terem
idéia
as duas meninas que participaram deste
projeto até aparecer aquela mais baixo
além da que está ao nosso lado esquerdo
a sabrina
existem idéias situação financeira da
família dela
então assim tão trágica ela ficou surda
em 2015 ela perdeu a audição primeira
perda de audição do ouvido esquerdo
depois ela perdeu a visão do olho
direito por causa de desnutrição na
infância
tá e então você vê a situação dos nossos
alunos na escola então continuando aqui
pessoal falando agora da pele humana o
outro projeto da pele humana para
transplantes e testes farmacológicos
messi vocês sabiam que quando as pessoas
no brasil estão à espera de um
transplante de pele tem 10 dias então
dar mais uns dados aqui pra vocês
esse é um dado de 2017 da a espécie de
um transplante de órgãos e o brasil
possui 60 mil pessoas à espera de um
transplante sendo que r 56 mil são
adultos quatro mil são crianças num ano
tá morre em torno dos 2300 pessoas à
espera da doação de um de um órgão para
transplante ou seja doação de pele é um
pouco maior que a doação de d&o dos
ossos enquanto a doação de ossos não
passa de 30 doação tarde doações anuais
no caso da pele um pouco mais já que já
vai estar com 50 doações anuais o brasil
ele tem cinco banco de peles é
localizados em curitiba porto alegre
recife rio de janeiro e são paulo eles
sobrevivem com resto de peles de
cirurgia plástica e quando tem assim
grandes acidentes é acaba importando
peles e e também o caso da rejeição de
peles como também ocorre na doação de
ossos o problema da rejeição
da pele o 12 de um ser humano pra outro
ser humano ainda tem esse problema da
rejeição também que ocorre com grande
freqüência a um milhão de pessoas
queimadas por ano pessoal aqui no brasil
sendo dessa tarde total de um milhão 10%
busca atendimento hospitalar enquanto
2015 em torno da pessoa de 2500
pacientes morrem por ano por motivo de
queimaduras acidentes com fogo é a
segunda causa de morte na infância tanto
no brasil como nos estados unidos e
então né conversamos ele com alguns
médicos mas também o que motivou a
desenvolver esse trabalho da da pele
humana foi o seguinte quando eu fiz o
concurso na escola na escola técnica eu
fiz o curso técnico em curtimento eu não
sei se vocês sabiam mas resiste à tona
apenas no brasil dois cursos técnico em
curtimento onde o aluno aprende a
trabalhar nem vai ser um técnico de
couro de curto aprender a trabalhar no
curtume
o curso mais antigo é existe em torno de
60 anos é oferta oferecido pelo senai no
rio grande do sul
e esse agora tudo centro paula souza que
eu me sinto na cidade de franca a cerca
de acho que uns 17 anos em e algumas
aulas práticas
elas são oferecidas dentro de curtos com
parceria com os curtumes
aí um dia eu tava com os alunos numa
dessas aulas práticas
aí de repente escutamos a gritaria
danada lá dentro do curtume era um
funcionário que estava carregando um
galão de 20 litros com ácido sulfúrico
sem tampa sem nenhuma proteção
ele foi subindo uma escada escorregou
aqueles 20 vitor caiu sobre ele ficou
cego na hora que 18 95% do corpo ele não
morreu mas se vocês situação quanto ele
gritava então isso a gente ficou assim
muito impressionado com isso aí já
passei por alguns pior vamos começar a
estudar há como obter pele humana tardin
através de metodologias mais simples
mais barata que trabalha acessível pra
gente
aí nós começamos o primeiro estudar
peles animais que mais se aproximavam da
da pele humana
não sei se vocês já viram na internet
aqueles curativos com pele isso depende
de tilápia
os médicos também conversei com alguns
médicos eles também fazem os curativos
com pele suína
só que até 11 quando começa a
cicatrização ele retirar as pedras da
tilápia quanto no caso se os russos a
pele suína porque elas são incompatíveis
com a pele humana
mas aí nós e um outro detalhe
interessante a pele suína ela possui o
que 78% de compatibilidade com a pele
humana
então vamos estudar com os atingiu 100%
de compatibilidade com a pele humana
então nós estudamos ou seja algumas
envolver os pais parecem metodologias né
eu sei que tem que eliminar pelo gordura
porque a pele isso naquela que virá a a
80ª pururuca
mas o que era incompatível as células do
epitélio então isso nós conseguimos
eliminar ou seja obtivemos uma pele uma
artificial 100% compatível com a pele
humana o que acontece num momento de um
transplante no caso de queimados é o
seguinte e o interessante é que no caso
da febre suína ela possui em torno de um
metro e meio metro e 80
tá então o médico ou seja vai utilizar
aquele pedaço ele referente à lesão e
essa pele suína é essa pele humana
artificial ela fica pra sempre no
paciente porque ela vai favorecer o
crescimento da pele do paciente sobre
ela tá aí em deter agora falam agora em
questões de cicatrização porque depende
do tamanho da lesão da pessoa mais
relacionado a questões de estética
nós já estamos produzindo essa pele está
próximo às cores negra vermelha e
amarela
tudo isso por causa é estética até o
momento que há na pele do paciente vai
crescer sobre ela
não é por exemplo o caso da pele negra o
contraste né
até o momento a cicatrização ou seja ela
fica para sempre no paciente
o valor principal existem metodologias
estados unidos e europa
d
a produção de pele humana e no
laboratório da usp também são paulo
começando a fazer mas assim comparar a
questão é é um metro ficaria o que em
torno de 10 e 15 mil reais aqui uma pele
um metro e meio r$85 pessoal
a transformação da pele suína em pele
humana artificial
aí vocês estão vendo a importância do
reaproveitamento de resíduos
então pessoal tivemos o que algumas
premiações e esse trabalho da pele
humana artificial foi um dos trabalhos
que ficou em exposição no museu do
amanhã no no rio de janeiro desde abril
até fevereiro agora desse ano ganhou o
prêmio curte política que é o
pesquisador do ano de 2014
aqui também participamos de olimpíada de
gênios onde a aluna foi ganhadora né nós
ali o alunos da iniciação científica o
professor há aqui foi um outro um outro
concurso que nós participamos nós somos
convidados a participar em los angeles
também e e também prêmio do conselho
regional de química
ai pessoal só falam de prémio prémio
prémio nem vou falar uma coisa
interessante para vocês é isso não conta
muito não mas até hoje em entre prêmios
nacionais e internacionais por 80
prêmios e temos que acusa a luz 15
patentes nacionais internacionais em 30
países e uma coisa um dado uma coisa
muito interessante foi o seguinte sempre
que eu falei pra vocês no início que a
maioria dos alunos é um nível social
muito baixo então tem muitos alunos que
nós já fizemos a vaquinha pra comprar de
cesta básica várias coisa então vocês
vêem hoje esses alunos recebendo
royalties
a mãe vindo agradecer que aquela mãe que
o que hoje ela é podre no supermercado
fazer uma compra mas os melhor os
maiores prêmios que recebi até hoje
pessoal foi o seguinte em 2016
um pai vem me procurar
dizendo que é ele morava a filha dele
estava fazendo iniciação científica
comigo ele morará mole mole próxima à
cidade de franca aluna e e voltava tudo
o dia segue para a cidade porque tem os
ônibus da prefeitura que leva os alunos
e porque assim o aluno teve na escola
com a gente mas a gente não sabe
infelizmente não dá para acompanhar a
vida do aluno fora da da escola
aí ele disse que a filha era garota de
programa néel os pais não separar da
menina morava com a mãe por causa desse
problema de garota de programa mães por
sua filha de casa a filha foi morar com
o pai e que ela começou a fazer a
iniciação científica e largou parou com
essa vida de garota de programa porque
diz que queria ser pesquisador uma
postura pesquisadora e o ano passado em
2017 uma um pai e uma mãe me procurou
dizendo que o filho de 16 anos saía da
escola já era por tráfico ficar com os
traficantes e que ele também tomou gosto
pela iniciação científica e largou a
vale a companhia do traficante que mudou
de bairro para ver se ele não tem mais
contato com esse pessoal e no final do
ano esses dois alunos eles foram
aprovados em química na universidade
federal do triângulo mineiro tavam serão
futuros pesquisadores e eja outra coisa
interessante que aconteceu em agosto do
ano passado
eu dei uma palestra na fundação casa na
fundação casa em franca e apresentei os
vários projectos álibi que os alunos
mostrei pra eles que eram alunos da
idade deles a linha eo mês passado a
psicóloga me ligou dizendo que três tá
três ali meninos já estão prestes a sair
agora nesse semestre e que querem ir à
escola e desenvolver projetos de
pesquisa e desses 31 fumar tou outro
robô zé traficante então a gente sim eu
falo que esses são os maiores prémios
porque a gente consegue plantar uma
semente ou seja a educação ela
transforma vidas que conseguiu plantar
uma sementinha no coração desses meninos
e agora já há a forma de trabalhar
porque tem uma lista enorme lad alunos
querendo fazer iniciação científica isso
conta gill a escola os professores
também começaram a desenvolver projetos
a incluir alunos dos projetos de
iniciação científica ali no meu caso
como eu faço a seleção dos alunos não é
por nota melhores notas como é
tradicional na graduação não eu eu
escolho primeiramente aquele está com a
vida mais vulnerável ou seja aquele que
está no tráfico aquele que a menina que
ela aqueles que têm problemas o primeiro
escolhido esse ai depois vou deixa os
outros no final os que estão bem com a
família estruturada para o final porque
a gente tudo isso porque eu percebi que
e príncipe não isso é real
a educação ela tem o poder de educação e
ciência tem o poder de transformar a
vida o nosso jovem adolescente ele tem
talento tá é você não precisa fazer
projeto simples com eles dá pra fazer
projetos inovadores como vocês viram
aqui no caso eles acompanham e estudam e
o interessante é que ele comece a
pesquisar fora daquele conteúdo da sala
de aula e até ajuda bastante quando eles
um enem no vestibular porque a maioria
dos alunos que fizerem iniciação
científica comigo e já terminaram na
escola a maioria com exceção de duas
alunas todos estão fazendo química tá
hoje aquele medo da química dos
construir aqui aquele medo daquilo que
eles bastará ter gosto pela quinta mas é
a forma que você mudar sair daquela
metodologia tradicional de ensino
isso é muito importante então pessoal eu
acho que nós temos é que acreditar no
jovem de hoje que serão os futuros
políticos médicos engenheiros e cabe a
nós educadores fazemos a diferença e
contribuir com o brasil porque o brasil
tem futuro a educação do brasil ela tem
futuro gente muito obrigada
[Aplausos]